Welcome to a discussion
about the music
for Hedwig and the Angry Inch.
Stephen Trask is a Grammy
Award-nominated composer,
musician, and
lyricist who composed
the music and lyrics
for the musical Hedwig
and the Angry Inch and the
subsequent film adaptation.
His other credits for film
include The Station Agent,
In Good Company, American
Dreamz, and Lovelace.
Stephen, thanks for joining us.
We're really excited
to talk to you.
Music is such an important
part of this project
and we'd love to hear a little
bit about the development.
Let's talk about adapting
your music and songs
from the Broadway musical
for the big screen.
One thing I definitely
knew I wanted to do was--
the look on the
screen was going to be
much more vivid and up close
than we had on the stage.
And the stage costumes
when they were up close,
they were serious but there
was also a jokey side to them.
But in the movie that
was a serious rock band
and I felt like
something I wanted
to do in the movie was
the music really needed
to sound like music that was
made by the people that looked
like that and put together
a really killer band that
was centered on Bob
Mould as a guitar player.
Who was one of my idols from
Hüsker Dü and then Sugar.
Who had become a fan of the
show and lived down the street
from the Jane Street Theater.
And we hung out
pretty regularly,
like he came by saw the
end of the show a lot.
He saw the show
a lot in general,
brought a lot of musicians
that I respected there.
And then he just hung out, we
became really close friends,
and I ended up dog
sitting for him a lot,
which was convenient because
it was right near the theater.
And then he was he was the
centerpiece of the recording
band.
So I tried to produce it with
a slightly less polished sound
than the cast album had
and just a little more raw.
And we're going to be talking
to Alex, but Alex Steyermark,
he led us through the
process of figuring out
how to get the sound of the
band coming out on the stage
while shooting so that the
extras could see what it--
could feel like they
were at a concert.
People that played
the musicians worked
really hard to learn their
parts and worked very closely
with the actual musicians.
We put on these
little fake concerts
on the set for the extras.
There was a lot of production
involved both on the day
and then leading up to it.
Besides giving all the
players their parts,
we would pre-record John, do
a master take of his vocal,
we would comp what we
thought was the ideal vocal,
and he would learn that.
When he sang live he was
singing having studied what--
that master take.
And then he would sing about
four or five times live
and then start lip syncing,
because how many times can you
sing and then still act a scene.
I'm not sure how much
of what we actually
did playing-wise in the movie
actually made it to the film.
But that drummer man,
Michael Aronov, he was just--
he hit every drum fill.
He made one mistake and
it haunts him to this day.
One cymbal he forgot to hit.
This project is very
interesting to me
because it started out in
such a simple form, such
a very pure form and
then kept expanding
from this kind of cabaret
or personal appearance act
and then moving
into more of a play
more into the movie.
So I'm just curious, what
was the feeling of Hedwig
for you as the composer?
As you were
composing these songs
and working on this
project over those years,
what was the feeling
of that character
that you musically
feel was consistent?
Like one of the
things that Hedwig
has that is sort of like--
some of it just comes
from me, and it's
inspired by a lot of
the same musicians,
but it's sort of an eclecticism.
I listen to a lot of
different kinds of music.
The songwriters that I
idolize listen to a lot
of different kinds of music.
When Hansel puts his head
in the oven early on,
it's Anne-Marie,
and Debby Boone,
and David Bowie, and
Iggy Pop, and Lou Reed.
It's not just the punk and
glam and avant garde stuff
that Hedwig liked, it was
an eclectic mix of things.
I would name chicks like
Patti Smith and Yoko Ono
but also Aretha Franklin
and also LaVern Baker.
Hedwig is a student of
rock music, you know,
and even to the point
of the essay that
gets Hansel thrown
out of University
is about the aggressive
influence of rock
and roll music and--
German philosophy on rock
and roll music and "You,
Kant, Always Get What You Want."
So this is something that
character was obsessed with
and I think that the
music is drawing--
however it's
expressed, it's drawing
on a lot of different
sources all at the same time.
And I think that's
why I'm trying
to translate it to the film.
It drew on all those
sources but it had a more--
the sound is more start
to finish cohesive than
in the original Off-Broadway
show where it felt like--
where it jumped genres a lot.
We got away with it
because we were on stage
and we were wearing
those costumes.
So this was your first feature,
and was this the first exposure
you had to filmmaking
in this way,
where you were a
major part of it...
Like in a professional sense?
Absolutely.
I did a-- did a movie
musical in college that
was a thesis film
for Miguel Arteta
and it won all sorts of
awards, like film festivals,
like Berlin Film Festival.
And I think it got a
Student Academy Award.
It was a similar sort of thing
where we actually had to--
like wrote the songs,
recorded the songs,
taught them to the actors,
performed them on the screen.
But it was obviously
for no money
and with student equipment.
But for what it was,
it was celebrated.
And I know they had a copy
of it on "Buffy the Vampire
Slayer" set and they watched it
a lot according to Joss Whedon.
That's terrific.
So it had its influence.
That's amazing.
So what was the transition
like for you to go into this?
Even though it was
an independent film
it was definitely, as you say,
a professional, major release
film.
You know I think I was--
I wasn't a kid.
I did this show for a year
at the Jane Street Theater.
And during that time we did
all sorts of appearances
and we recorded an
album and we tried
to launch the show
in some other cities
and it didn't work because
the productions were unwieldy.
So by that time I was
just sort of like,
it was just sort of like
walking into a new room
of a house for me.
And with definitely different
responsibilities but it
didn't feel like Oh my
God what's this new thing.
It was like Oh this--
it was just very exciting
new ways of doing the thing,
if that makes sense.
Completely.
I do want to bring Alex
into the conversation now,
so Alex Steyermark has worked
as a music supervisor, editor,
and producer since 1998
on projects as varied
as The Boxer, The Ice Storm,
and, of course, Hedwig
and the Angry Inch.
His feature film directorial
debut had a musical kick
to it---
Prey for Rock & Roll.
Please welcome Alex Steyermark.
Alex come on board.
Hello.
So I think the first
thing, you know,
music supervisor is
one of those titles
that I think people think
they have an idea of what it's
like to supervise
music, but I don't
think they really know what that
entails on a day-to-day basis.
So could you two talk about
your working relationship
and how the composer and
music supervisor work together
to get a cohesive sound
and cohesive feel?
Well, I think the job,
the music supervisor
is something that is different
depending on the film.
And I think the needs of a
movie dictate what that is.
And I also think that different
people bring different skill
sets to it.
For me, it's that I had studied
film but also studied music
my whole life.
So I always came
at it from the sort
of filmmaker's side with
a sensitivity, I guess,
to how music is created.
On this particular film,
which was a massive actually
a massive endeavor given
the amount of music
in the film and the fact that
both John and Stephen were
making their first film.
It was a very complex
project and I had sort of
become known as someone who
was good with on-camera films
with on-camera
performances as well.
So I was brought
in by, originally,
by the producer of the
film, Christine Vachon,
to meet and talk with Stephen
and John about the film.
It also helped that I had a lot
of music production experience.
Also I had seen the show
at the Jane Street Theater
so what seemed to be one of
the challenges of the film
was to translate the intensity
of what it was like to actually
be in the theater
and see and feel
viscerally the music that
you felt as an audience
member sitting in a
theater with live music.
And that was sort of a guiding
principle throughout and how we
approached filming the scenes.
And there was-- as
Stephen said, there
was a lot of actual on-set
music production taking place.
Another challenge was that John
was both director and star.
And so that was a very
physically demanding task
that I don't even
think John really
realized he was getting into.
And so it was a matter of
recreating that intensity
on film of the live show.
It was also having it--
sort of, organizing
the filming and the
production of the music
around physical
limitations also budget,
it was not a big budget film.
And we had to be fairly
resourceful in how we did
that, how we approached that.
Stephen, when Alex
came on board what
was that kind of getting to
know each other process like?
The best part of the
getting to know you process
was, in addition to recording
the songs, which all happened
before the shooting,
I scored the film,
I wrote the instrumental score
that went throughout the film
but I had no equipment.
I had a four track machine
and I had a TV with a VCR.
I don't think I even had a
remote control for my TV,
so like the idea of pressing
play and pressing record
and then getting to pick up
my instrument with my one
microphone-- it just it was
trying to write music for it.
I could write the music but
I couldn't write it really
for it.
And so I actually wrote all of
the demo cues in Alex's office
with Alex recording me while
I would watch the movie there.
And sometimes write
it there in the room.
You know it's weird
to think about now
because like I can do
almost anything with scoring
in a computer.
But Alex had what
I think at the time
was very sophisticated computer
technology for putting the--
editing the music and
sticking it into the picture
but looking back on it
was very, very primitive
sort of technology.
Right Alex?
Certainly by today's
standards, it was primitive.
But we had a lot of fun with it.
It was appropriate for the
circumstances in a way.
You had to be pretty inventive.
And it was.
And it was-- I just
remember working really--
being there after hours.
We were in your office
till really late at night.
We were, and when
it came to the score
there was also a question of--
we're getting away from the
actual songs and everything
but the score is a big
part of it actually.
Even though there's
not a lot of it,
it plays a very important role.
And we were searching for
what that's actually--
what the thematic
material should be.
And at a certain
point, it dawned on us
that really we should
take the melodic material
from a song that was
already in the film
and use that as the theme,
the thematic material
for the score.
So then when we
get to the end it's
just this tremendous
cathartic release,
which I think you're
not completely
aware of as an audience
member but it's there.
We're so focused on the song
and that was beautiful actually.
The world was just so--
was so tight and coherent
that it didn't really--
it wasn't looking
for new material.
It wasn't looking
for a new song,
it wasn't looking
for new anything.
It just wanted to be fleshed
out and so like picking up
on themes that were already in
the songs, particularly "Origin
Of Love," and using
that in a few spots.
I think the flying
music is unique unto
itself and it had to bridge--
it had to somehow be score
but like the flying music had
to somehow feel like it was
in the same musical world
as the "Angry Inch"
which was fading out
and the beginning
of "Wig in a Box"
which when the flying
music is over you're there.
Basically it bridges
those two worlds
and it had to feel like
it was in that space
without being a song.
And like now when
I score a film,
I actually like I
know how to do that.
Like it's a very-- like it--
say someone like gives me a
film with a lot of songs in it,
I know how to figure out how
to do stuff that can go in
between the songs and it's
not really that big a deal
but then it felt like a
really heavy lift for me.
And I guess like
the other was like--
what-- you did-- you did that
live performance in a Spike Lee
movie right, Alex?
Sure, many of them, yeah.
I love Spike Lee and I
loved all those movies.
So one, I just felt
like I was in good hands
when we were
introduced and when you
were brought into our world.
But also feeling like knowing
that we were doing it right
and figuring out
that way of mixing
live performance and
pre-recorded performance
and mimicked live performance
on the set like that
was the thing that you
taught us how to do.
And so--
I've always been, especially
with this kind of music,
I've always believed
pretty strongly that it's--
to the extent that
it can be done,
it's important to
do live vocals.
It's more believable when
you see it coming out
of the actor's mouth.
We had the fortunate
situation that John
was both a great actor
and a great singer.
Those basic ingredients
were already there.
Initially the
producers of the film
were wondering why
we couldn't just
do lip-sync, which is what most
people were doing certainly
at the time.
And for me, it was
just clear that again,
that if we were going to
recreate the energy that we
felt in the theater and if we
were going to believe that what
we were seeing on screen
was really happening
we had to do it
with live vocals.
And so with that being
said, as Stephen mentioned,
we pre-recorded everything,
all of the instrumental tracks,
we pre-recorded John's vocals,
background vocals, as well.
And which-- so when we
were filming the musicians
were actually miming
their instruments
but John was singing live
and we were playing back
the instrumental
tracks in the room
over loudspeakers so that
the actors could hear.
We were using real
stage microphones,
which are pretty good
at isolating the voice.
And whenever-- I'd
say it's probably
90% or more live
vocals in the film.
And we use the prerecorded
vocals because John--
it was just very,
very demanding.
I don't know that John, I'm
sure that John didn't realize
how demanding it would be.
It's one thing to
go through a show
from beginning to end
in a couple of hours.
It's another thing to spend
eight hours in a day singing
the same song over and over
again without blowing out
your voice.
And so whenever we
weren't filming John then
we would be playing back the
prerecorded vocals, which
is what the extras or the
audience in the scenes
would be responding to or
what Stephen and the rest
of the band would be miming to.
The band did play
everything note perfect.
Yes.
I remember the drummer had--
coming out of the
drummer's monitor
was the drummers part
loud enough so that--
for the audience the
sound of the drums
seemed to really actually
be coming from the drums.
And that was something that
made it feel more live.
Every day it felt like a live--
it felt like a musical
production unto itself.
I'm pretty sure that
a lot of the extras
actually thought they
were hearing live music
like entirely live performance.
They mentioned that,
they were like, "wow,
you guys played great".
We were like, uh-huh, thank you.
What's one of your favorite
moments musically in the film?
Well, here's one.
With me singing Tommy's version
of 'Wicked Little Town.'
Something really nice
happened in that recording.
I remember Bob coming up
with an amazing guitar,
like did something to the
guitar part that just brought it
to a new level.
But it wasn't just Bob.
And Tim O'Heir was recording
it and he got a great sound.
And everyone played
really well and something
about that recording.
And then when sung
by Michael Pitt who
has that beautiful face.
Not sung by him, but he's
lip syncing to me singing.
It just-- I don't know,
that one recording
has a very special sound to it.
I remember that,
actually, when we did that
and it's very vivid.
You were so in another place,
as a performer you were really
feeling the part.
I remember that it was like you
were acting it in the studio
and I think that's
why it feels that way.
That makes sense because
I also had to method act
the writing of the song.
So singing it was an
extension of that.
Like just to write it, I
had to be somebody else.
And so, yeah, I remember
being in the studio
and feeling that, going and
being that other person.
And then it just came
out really special.
How was it determined
that you were going
to sing that role for Tommy?
I demanded it.
What was there about that that
made you want to demand it?
I knew I could sing it right.
And you know we had done
the cast album with Atlantic
Records and they
actually only wanted
to do the soundtrack if we
let one of their big stars
be Tommy Gnosis.
And it would have
been Scott Weiland
and he's like, you know he would
have sung the shit out of it,
but it definitely would
have been Scott Weiland.
Like it wouldn't have
been Tommy Gnosis singing,
it would have been
Scott Weiland singing.
Michael Pitt could
have mouthed it,
but you'd have know who it was.
And I wanted to do it,
so I just kind of like--
we were very much--
when we shot this movie
we took a lot of
meetings and gave
the pitch of what we wanted to
do and how we wanted to do it.
And it was written
into the contract
that my band was
going to be the band.
My band broke up,
but they were going
to be the band in the movie
and on the recordings.
And if there were
any disagreements
about musical elements,
the film company
could weigh in, but that
I had the tie breaking
vote over the director
and the film studio.
Like these weird--
we just demanded--
like John demanded stuff, we
demanded stuff and then New
Line was willing to give it
to us and Atlantic wasn't.
And we ended up selling the--
Alex sold the soundtrack later
to Hybrid Records that got
lost I think in a card game.
And--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
Something like that, right?
Well, we have to find out.
But we would go around
and give our little pitch
to all these film
studios and they
would just kind of like look at
us like, "who are these people,
they're crazy".
Like we'd talk about doing this
sort of improv John Cassavetes
thing where there's a lot
of not talking and whatever.
And sort of like what I'm doing
right now and they would just
be like, "uh-huh", really
awkward lunches and then--
until finally New Line
was actually interested.
It found the right home.
Yeah.
So Alex, going back to the
beginning of being brought on
to kind of create
this film music sound
and at the same time ending
up selling the soundtrack.
I mean it sounds like you had
quite an interesting journey
with this film.
I'm just wondering what are
some of the pieces along the way
that you found particularly
personal for you?
Well, first of all, I loved
the show to begin with.
So when I was asked to work
on the film I was thrilled.
I didn't know John or
Stephen at the time.
It was very complex and it got--
it was one of those projects
where I got to do everything
that I like to do.
Which is, frankly, be involved
in creating the music as
opposed to some
of the other roles
that music supervisors
often play like clearances
and licensing and so on.
So for me I loved
that aspect of it,
I've always preferred
that part of it.
The greatest thing
that came out of it,
frankly, was getting
to know Stephen
and becoming close
friends with him.
Stephen, in fact, produced the
music for my directorial debut
a couple of years later,
PRAY FOR ROCK & ROLL,
which you mentioned.
So if you're lucky, you get
to work on a lot of films
and meet people,
but it's not often
that you actually meet someone
that you just feel so--
such a rapport with
that extends beyond just
the working experience
that you have together.
So at the same time it's a
great film, it's a lot of fun.
I like watching it with other
people who are discovering it
themselves for the first
time and seeing that it still
resonates with people.
And it's a big success in
terms of what we set out to do.
We did create a movie that,
for lack of a better word,
kicks ass musically.
And that's what we wanted to do,
you know and I think it does--
definitely does that.
Kicks ass is definitely
I think the proper phrase
for this film.
Was Hedwig a hit
right away or was it
something that you really had
to work to keep this project
moving?
At what point did
it start to get
a little momentum of its own?
We always were scraping by even
when we seemed to be a hit.
It was always a heavy
boulder rolling up a hill.
Even on Broadway, like
Neil's run was sold out
but when the run started his
first night was sold out,
but the second
night was half sold.
It wasn't until the
first show ended
and the word got out that
he was actually really good
that tickets started selling.
It always requires
a push, you actually
can't let it just go
of its own momentum
because if you
don't stay involved
it kind of loses whatever
is special about it.
It shouldn't feel like
a piece of commerce,
it should feel like a piece
of queer, punk theater.
And the queer and the punk
parts have to both be there.
Like it can't just be queer
and it can't just be punk,
it's queer, punk theater.
And that like--
John and I are queer punks and
like not everybody else is.
So we have to keep our
fingers in the pie.
So can you talk about,
again, this project
started as kind of
just a drag performance
in a very small
space and then moved
to more of a theatrical venue.
Can you talk about how Hedwig
changed in order to do that?
The big element that
came along was getting--
sort of organizing philosophy
for how to present it.
Which is, the show is
always happening wherever
the show happens to be.
And so like when we were at--
when we did it on Broadway,
the place that the
show was happening
was the Belasco Theater.
And Hedwig talked about
being at the Belasco Theater.
And then there's
the question, well,
how is this total
nobody who was a failure
get onto a Broadway stage?
Well, then that
becomes part of--
that becomes part of
the story that she--
in that case a show had closed.
A show had closed on opening
night, "Hurt Locker -
the Musical", which is a
name that Michael made up.
And their set was still there
and Hedwig gives a blowjob
to the guy that runs the
theater-- is actually
the guy that runs the whole
Schubert Organization.
And he gave her the theater
for just this one night.
But like some of it was
just like learning new ways
to kind of do the same thing.
Like when we first did
it at Fez under Time Cafe
and we had recordings of
Tommy Gnosis off stage.
Like we didn't have a budget
so John came over to my house
and we hooked a microphone up
to a guitar amp with reverb so
he could sound like
he was in the stadium.
And then I put that on one
channel of a four track
and then on the other channels
I recorded little snippets
of crowd noise from The
Concert for Bangladesh
on tracks 2, 3, and 4.
And they were never
really long enough to keep
going so I would just keep
cross-fading from 2 to 3 to 4,
to 2 to 3 to 4 to, 2,
3, to 4 so that Tommy
could be talking
and saying his stuff
and the crowd could
be responding.
It was a makeshift version
of what we ended up doing.
But it was that
philosophy of being
where you are that we found
was the thing that worked.
Does that answer your question?
Very much so and
it's not the answer
I would have expected
so thank you very much.
You mentioned earlier that you
were both queer and both punk
and all that.
And obviously you had your music
sensibility and your music side
of the story.
And John was more the
performer and writer, perhaps.
But what do you
see as the things
that you and John brought
to this that gave it
the cohesiveness and that gave
it the yin and the yang, so
to speak?
I kind of write half the words
that come out of Hedwig's mouth
and John writes the
other words that
come out of Hedwig's
mouth, but it all
has to sound like Hedwig.
So we had to be very
much of one mind.
And so a lot of the work--
it came out of
long conversations.
Like, just long
days and nights just
spent talking about
the various issues that
related to the show.
And really getting into
dualities and binaries
and breaking those open.
Looking at a lot of philosophy
and religious philosophy
and all of this stuff and
just long conversations.
So that when you
went to write, it
wasn't necessarily
that you went to write
with an instruction for what was
going to happen in the story,
but you're writing from the
perspective of coming out
of these conversations
where the two of us
were just engaged in this thing.
What we ended up writing was
just us talking to each other.
Talking to each other
in a way that we thought
would entertain our friends.
In the back of our
mind, it was some day
going to be something
else, but I think for me,
and I'm pretty sure for John,
like the most immediate thing
was we're writing to
each other and we're
going to show it to our
friends who know us.
And I think that's why it has
that feeling of yin and yang
like totally come together.
Alex, you observed
them working together
and observed the
making of the film.
What are the different
pieces that they each bring
to the mix, so to speak?
I knew a lot about the creative,
the collaborative process,
how the show had been created
even before I met them.
And I knew that it
would be super stressful
for both of them.
And so because it
was their first film,
because film is usually a
director's medium, you know.
And here we had
a situation where
we had two creative
partners who were
both equally important to
the success of the show
and of the concept.
In this case, also Stephen
was a creative collaborator
in the making of the film.
And so that was also different
and usually the music creator
is not in that position.
So I was always very
mindful, I was always
trying to be respectful
of both John and Stephen's
equal partnership in
the creation of Hedwig,
the idea of Hedwig.
Part of my role, besides all the
other things we talked about,
was sort of navigating
the creative process
that each one of them
would have to go through
to create the movie.
So that each of them could
do what they had to do.
Honestly, I spent
a lot of time just
trying to understand
where each of them
was coming from so
that we could guide,
from the musical part of
it, that process forward.
I think it's a testament
to their relationship.
They made the film and then they
went on and did the Broadway
show, they have--
this is a very special entity,
John and Stephen and Hedwig.
This world that they've created.
One of the things that was
different about the movie
was that our spheres stopped
happening in the same space.
Recording all the
music for the film
and then turning
it into an album
and then recording the score,
it was this entirely other
production that had
to fit with the film,
but they were happening
in different spaces.
And John and I really
didn't like see each other.
Whereas, when you're
doing it on stage,
it was me and John and
Peter Askin and Miriam--
and I would have a
piano and a guitar
and we would just be
sitting around a table
and just performing it there.
And then you get onto the
stage and the band is there
and you're all working
together in the same room.
But we kind of like, kind of
went off into our own spheres.
And it's true with
any musical film,
it's actually more
than one production.
You have the film production,
but before all of that happens
you have maybe a couple of
months of the music production.
You're rehearsing first the
band that you have to prerecord,
and John who was
singing, then you
have to rehearse the actors who
are going to be in the film.
And all of this has to happen
even before you can roll film.
And then afterwards,
the film is done
and then we did go
and do all the album
mixes which was like a
whole other production.
There were a lot
of moments where--
the what was happening
in the music sphere
was separate from what
was happening in the film.
What's your favorite
moment in the film
or some of your favorite
memories from the shoot?
One, I loved doing the
improvisational scenes
that got cut.
But there were all
sorts of things
that we did that
sometimes just ended up
being like an overhead
shot in the hotel room.
Therese had this
great thing where
in addition to touring around
the same fish restaurant,
her idea was that we
were in the same hotel--
motel chain throughout the tour.
So the four walls were
always the same four walls.
But as the tour went on,
we had less and less money,
our room kept getting smaller.
So at the beginning
of the tour, we're
in a kind of spacious room and
we're all kind of spread out.
And at the end of the tour, the
room is the width of the bed
and then there's just
like a little place
to stand that's just wide enough
to open the door to get in.
So it's the same decor that just
kept getting closer and closer.
My memory of it is
that it was a blur.
It was a very tight schedule
and there was so much to do.
It was non-stop activity
from morning to night.
A lot of it was, to
be honest, was also
getting John to pace himself
so that he wouldn't burn out
because he would
throw himself into it.
And again, he was
directing so he
was looking at the
monitor in costume,
you know, and then having to
run out and sing and perform.
To be honest, I was
a little concerned.
He had to make it to
the end so a lot of it
was just getting him to not use
up all his energy in one moment
because he had a lot to do.
Filming 'Midnight Radio' was
pretty intense, you know.
It was a puzzle, actually,
of how to put it together.
I still kind of
feel like this jolt
when I see that in the film.
Especially when we
cut to Miriam falling
back and the whole thing.
Alex was mentioning like getting
John to pace himself and how
much work he was doing-- on the
visual side like Therese was
like--
of all the people
on the visual side,
she was the most
experienced, but I
think Alex probably brought the
most film experience of anybody
to this movie.
You know, I could feel
that when we first
started working together.
And it was very important
to me, actually Alex,
to either impress you
or to get your approval,
but like that sense
of Alex has done this,
he knows what this is-- like
I felt in very good hands.
And bringing you into
the world-- like it
felt right to bring
you into there.
I'm glad you brought me into it.
Thank you.
Yeah, me too.
Stephen, Alex, I want to thank
you both for this conversation.
It's really great to talk
about your collaboration
on this film with the music.
And it's also great to
see that you've each
found a friend so
congratulations
and thank you very much.
Thank you.
Thanks for asking me
to be a part of it.
Sorry you are up at
4:00 in the morning
but I don't think this
is the first time.
No.
It's like the good
old days, Stephen.